bonjour katia technique que s'est il dit
à l'ouverture de ce procès alors c'est
un procès historique 1 je veux juste te
rappeler que c'est un procès sous haute
surveillance un procès historique mais
également un immense procès puisque
quasiment tout le deuxième étage ici au
tribunal de paris a été réquisitionnée
il y à de nombreux camions de gendarmes
des forces de l'ordre sont prêts sont
ici un peu partout dans le tribunal et
puis il y à de nombreux contrôles un
détecteur de métaux dont pour assister
aux audiences
alors pour le moment on imagine un début
de procès une ambiance très lourde
derrière les masques on a pu distinguer
les visages de risque de de coco de
patrick peloux également de lassana bâti
lit le magasinier de l'hyper cacher et
puis évidemment les prévenus donc sont
arrivés ils sont bien sûr masqué menotté
entouré de forces de l'ordre
cagoulés et le président a expliqué
qu'il pourrait répondre à des questions
ils vont être interrogés ils ont a
priori tous accepté de faire des
déclarations et donc concernant ces
prévenus par exemple il ya ali riza
polak qui est considéré comme le bras
droit d'amérique ou l'e-mail et qui lui
a fournis et des arts et justement
l'avocate de ali riza paul at il à bell
coûtant peyre s'est exprimée elle a émis
des conclusions elle a expliqué qu'elle
compatissait mais qu'elle estimait que
ce drame aurait pu être évité si les
services de surveillance et de sécurité
avaient fait leur travail ce sont ses
termes un expliquant que la surveillance
des sociétés trois personnes avaient
cessé quelques mois avant les attentats
et puis elle s'est interrogé pourquoi
les autres fournisseurs d'armes des
terroristes n'ont pas été poursuivis
sont justes poursuivi pour trafic
d'armes et donc pour complicité elle
demande un supplément d'information
concernant les avocats se sont pour le
moment quasiment les seuls à s'être
exprimé devant les journalistes il
n'aborde pas tous le procès dans le même
état d'esprit
certains sont déçus estimant qu'il ne
s'agit que de sous fifres des
terroristes qui sont jugés aujourd'hui
et d'autres comme un des avocats des
parties civiles a expliqué qu'il
s'agissait du procès de la défaite de la
laïcité
et puis je vous propose également
d'écouter thibault de montbrial
avocat d'une des anciennes journaliste
de charlie hebdo zineb el rhazoui nous
avons des gens en france qui continue à
promouvoir et à défendre l'islamisme que
ce soit par bêtise par déni par lâcheté
ou par complicité
il faut le dénoncer c'est un combat pour
la démocratie pour la liberté pour la
république qui se déroule dans cette
salle d'audience mais qui se déroule
également en dehors de cette salle voilà
pour ce début de procès de charlie hebdo
un procès historique sous haute
surveillance que nous suivrons tout au
long de cette journée